and I got a phone call I was out doing
the shopping at Tescos for my wife
because that's kind of guy I am and I
was just sitting contemplating playing
candy crush on my phone before I went
home
that's one packet all and I got a phone
call from my managing director at the
company I work for
it's actually my company so he works for
me and and he said H without the police
in we've had a fella called P Siegel
wanting to speak to you he said I'm not
getting I'm not giving him your number
because that's down to him and you but
he wants to speak to you he hasn't told
what it's about
but he needs to speak to you so here's
his number so okay Mike I'll give him a
ring back so I rang P Siegel back and I
said okay make what what what have I
done he said ah are you Harry the owl on
social media I said yeah absolutely I am
he said okay so we've had a we've had a
complaint in from somebody down south so
right okay you doing this is
Lincolnshire right he's not down south
it says yeah but they're very concerned
about the transgender people in your
workplace I said but as far as I know
down an aiming him doc I haven't got any
transgender people in my workplace so
what does it matter it doesn't matter
you might have and maybe you haven't got
any because you're a hateful bigot all
right what what about well apparently
been posting these on social media which
makes your workplace a very dangerous
place for trans people I said let's just
let's just back up a minute here let's
just back up a minute I said have I done
anything criminal have I committed
anything criminal it's a no no you're
not committed any crime not no crime
whatsoever
I said so in that case why why are you
why are you ringing me no said oh I need
to check your thinking and I said now
old on a minute just one one second
you're a police officer yep and your
ring me to check my thinking yeah I said
have you any idea what that makes you
you
[Music]